MLB Network insider and analyst Peter
Gammons here on the show to discuss and
how are you Peter I'm doing very well
rich III think I know how people feel
but in terms of entertainment it's kind
of like you know it's taking a little
bit of March Madness and applying it to
baseball and I mean that that the plane
will wear go home
thing is is really compelling in
baseball and I think it creates it's
fast
the only problem with it this time it's
just all right today is you start
playing on Tuesday or you start playing
on Thursday but I get that but I think
it's still very compelling I thought
yesterday was a phenomenal day even
though the games were pretty well
decided by the third or fourth inning it
was still a great day of sitting
watching and I think it's the same way I
think it's all started back in 2011 when
the Red Sox and Braves each had ten game
leads going into September and it got
down to the final night of the season
and Carl Crawford didn't catch the fly
ball in left field the Red Sox lost of
the Orioles they were out then my Gori
hit the home run in Yankee Stadium the
Braves lost in they're playing the game
they were out and that was like the
beginning that was such a story at the
time now obviously not every year you
get collapse of 10 games like game
collapses as the Braves and Red Sox head
mean but at the same time they found it
really compelling and I think I was
skeptical about the play in games I'm
not now I think it really creates a lot
and there's there's so much potential
havoc it kind of reminds me again of the
Final Four of Jim Valvano saying just
win and survive find a way to win and
move on and don't even think about why
you did it just do it and go I know the
leaders but because you have such a wild
game I know that but today's non-service
today's not survive in advance it's
losing advance
and and so y-yeah what about nineteen
regular season games I mean they're just
it's it's not you use up your pitching
staff right
if the Brewers have to use seven
relievers today and lose good luck to
them tomorrow exactly so why put them in
that position at all like like the the
the filet mignon is October petered like
there's no reason to serve me something
terrific an entree now I'm ready for the
real entree tomorrow and Wednesday and
Beyond there's no reason to put teams in
any position that might weaken them for
the actual win or go home is what I'm
saying right um it's America now I think
personally they should do is eliminate
this ridiculous idea which ruling which
really does discount September of
allowing more than 25 players to be on
the roster I mean they get a 40-man
roster today which is which means we
could see like that's true seventeen
granny granny jokes pitch in the game
but in its I mean there was a guy just
help a 5-4 ter a in Korea two years ago
who gets to Bible innings for the Cubs
yesterday Alan Webster and the closer
and if the finisher was what was
dilarosa who when he signed with the Red
Sox in 2003 Dan Duquette said was the
Mexican John Rocker next year of course
they traded him for Curt Schilling is
almost forgotten right it's it's crazy
but I think September has been so
diminished that you know it's it's okay
just have a have a tournament and
because it certainly doesn't make sense
in basketball the the I mean you can
have you can finish first in the ACC and
get knocked out by Appalachian State and
or you can get end up in the semi-finals
with someone who finished fourth them in
the league and they end up they move
ahead of you I I just read more game
where is all on the line are good for
baseball because the season passes and
you know there's always others are
tomorrow and I think this eliminates
tomorrow and makes it really area now
the fact that in this today we have four
really compelling teams who have
developed tremendous rivalries over this
year really no I I hear you but I guess
let's let's move on to to to actual
playoff games they're gonna be taken on
significance within a matter of days are
you concerned about Chris sales velocity
should the Red Sox be going into this
yes now Chris Sale never blames anything
else you know he never blames anybody
else he just he's a very you know right
down the middle guy and don't worry I'll
get my mechanics back and he never it's
it's always you know it's on me don't
worry I'll get this done but of course
there were ninety point one mile an hour
in his last start and you know watching
that watching it over the tape of it he
was not getting any extension he wasn't
getting push off his it is this leg now
that may be mechanical but can you write
those mechanics into bullpen sessions I
don't know and I mean I think the Red
Sox Yankees series is you know we all
thought they were dead even when the
season started and they both have their
ups and downs I think right now they're
dead even again I think it's a
fascinating series but it's not dead
even at Chris Ale the Red Sox have to
win that series where they're starting
pitching and but the Yankees could win
the series were their bullpen well I
guess it's I guess Peter Gammons it
wouldn't be even if the A's show up
there and they've had a terrific go yeah
they'll start with the opener and
they've got the best bullpen in the
American League they can easily go out
and shut you down for two runs over nine
innings a win match happened it's a
three-run homer in their home
I was listening the one person on our
network say that nobody in America wants
the A's to win well I know some people
in Oklahoma a store but that's it
it's a fascinating case I don't think
the A's can maintain it overseas
I think the Yankees can sew it there are
a lot of pieces to that whereas the
other series in America like I think the
two best teams in baseball and it's
going to be it's going to be an
incredible series watching Houston play
Cleveland I I just I it takes my breath
away because I think they're both so
good and so deep in terms of their
pitching staffs it's so that has to be
seven games we're hoping it yeah I mean
that that is gonna be truly a fun watch
who do you think the Yankees start on
Wednesday is it gonna be happy do you
think they go Severino what do you think
Aaron Boone is gonna do I think I think
he's actually gonna go Tanaka really
ringing and get him three or four
innings and then go get keep half 2
pitch against the Red Sox twice I mean
that's kind of been my feeling Tom
Verducci kind of feels the same way
he's just their most reliable guy he's
the best pitcher against the red side
he's really good plus he's always been
good from his from mr. allo days
pitching in Fenway Park I think he's
eight and four lifetime in Fenway Park
and he's your most reliable guy now
that's a gamble to do that but if they
figure okay we'll go bull count against
bullpen
Yankees A's then then maybe I mean maybe
that's the way he goes us but my
guessing it's safer to go Happ
but the one thing about is that one of
the things that the Yankees are so good
they're right-handed power
I guess left-handed pitching they're
right-handed hitters hit the ball to
right field and that BAM box of a
ballpark it's all right field because of
any team in baseball I mean I think they
get 47 opposite field home runs in
this year the next team's highest the
next highest total of opposite field
home runs by right-handed hitters at
home is 12 by Baltimore and the Yankees
are really but the second team in terms
of opposite field right hand power in
baseball are the A's so you know maybe
you're better off with with a
right-hander and then go to your bullpen
you it's pretty much all right-handed in
Yankee Stadium and then you pitch happen
Boston which is more of a left-handed
pitchers Park okay last one for you
Peter and a couple minutes to have with
you left who has the Advanta
well you know who's in okay none of the
none of today means anybody gets
eliminated who who do you think has the
best team in the NL and makes the World
Series
I saw a month ago I put Colorado but now
I'm not so convinced yes and last
Marquez was breaking ball just
combination Dodgers I think it's not
just still the deepest team and have
them they have the most step in the most
ways they can win especially now the
Bueller's join Kershaw and Hill and Rio
who highly underrated big-game pitcher I
just think that that they're there to be
for seemingly but this game today
they're both great because the pores are
really fun and what they did at the
trading deadline to take them from about
a 17 player team to a 25 clarity my I
just david stern's did an incredible job
and Dodgers Dodgers Rockies phenomenal
to it so the Rockies have had the
deepest starting pitching in the league
and the Dodgers are the deepest team so
it's going to be really fun I can't wait
Peter thanks for the call really
appreciate it we'll chest enjoy October
you got a Peter Gammons can be seen on
MLB Network throughout the postseason
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience